so caste and politics in India will
explore all these different facets of
the topic I'm sure if you allow me a
preface a short preface I would like to
say two things rather quickly and
there's no need for me to stand for
saying this on a personal point first
I'm really very happy that Columbia and
the siltation
Institute have placed this conference on
caste in India under the edges of
America who was indeed a scholar and one
of us in many ways a sociologist before
others before many others even though is
not yet in the readers where it should
be
facility of India but we must remember
that this acknowledgement of its
accomplishments came after decades of
neglect and I never miss an opportunity
to recall that ten years ago only we had
no biography of America in English
except the one by care that was written
in 54 and that was rather controversial
well as we had so many candies Naros GB
pants what else this is something we
have to remember all the time because it
means that there was a longer virtue at
the limit of his accomplishment that is
now taking place and this conference is
of course part of this longer virtue
acknowledgement and the next step
probably should be that well under
capture my only fear is that this in
that process of acknowledgement we may
lose one aspect of Ambedkar sorry that
was the core identity of the man he was
a rebel
till the end he fought till the end and
he died a bitter man so it's not an
establishment man even his suit
is just telling us I dare being like you
I'm not the establishment man I can be I
could be and he said it but it was a
fighter first the second point quickly I
want to make is that it's not at all
inappropriate to begin such a conference
with politics we could have started with
other things but politics it's a rather
good entry point precisely if we go by
Ambedkar's views of society and and the
world even as it said protects is the T
power is the key on the route to
emancipation empowerment in empowerment
there is power so there is politics and
the panelists I'm going to introduce now
will precisely look at politics in many
different ways because there are many
ways of course of looking at politics in
this context they may not even refer to
party politics they may not even
pronounce the word election at any rate
but that will be politics anyway and I'm
sure the humanization will help us to
bring back some of the more conventional
way we have to look at politics so let
me introduce quickly the three speakers
the Treecko panelists in the reverse
order of the representation she vodka me
first ladies first
who has been in government service for a
long time from 79 to last year in the
IAS and as I as an IAS officer she has
been collector she has been secretary to
arraignment of Tamilnadu in Adi Dravida
and tribal welfare department it reminds
me of what Pratap said about the 69
percent of the reservation in in Tamil
Nadu even a department for a deeper
video on tribal welfare which is not
something you'll find in the north so
easily and she is now a novelist he has
to restore novels after leaving the
government
for some of them two of them are
available accessible in English
the others are in Tamil I suppose and
she is editing a Tamil Journal I'll give
you the title in English because I'm
able to do it otherwise they delete
delete' literary journal that is
functioning since 1995 dr. Anand Elton
Bay is well known as an activist and a
human right man in Maharashtra but also
in the rest of India it was born in a
family of landless laborers in Vidarbha
region of Maharashtra that is the
eastern part of Maharashtra he has been
top-ranking students pros earning his be
in mechanical engineering from the NIT
in Nagpur is MBA from the I am of a
murder but and he has done his doctorate
in management focusing on a pioneer area
of cybernetic modeling for public
systems dr. Tunde it is very well known
for all the research he has done on
caste and especially the Dalits in India
I will mention only two books among many
others two books you may have read
already because they have really made an
impact Kalonji a strange and bitter crop
that came out two years ago sorry last
year only and and we come back we'll go
back to Kalonji I'm sure after enduring
this presentation and the other book is
slightly older anti-imperialism and
cognition of caste this very phrase of
course comes from on that exact muli
valve engine is as in professor in
anthropology
I like this periodicity nari T of the
panel and is very active
maybe not an activist but then we had
live anyway so you are an active is very
good I wanted to say the word but it's
not in you that in your builder as I
didn't dare to do it so easily
Davis and underscore as well a scholar
who has Co edited and written two books
I'd like to quote among many others
against stigma studies in caste race and
justice since Durban so we are back to
the International context and this book
has been cool edited by M and Paul
Greenup it will be published or it has
been published this year but I don't
know you don't say orange Longman
anymore you say orient BlackSwan but
this is same place and the other book is
forthcoming crafting caste in India cast
into cultural community and rutledge
will be bishops in London and I hope
also in India because it will be more
well
it'll be cheaper the last thing I want
to mention is an article by him an
article that may set the term of the
panel it came this July it came out this
July in EPW a great article quickly in
electoral Indian electoral democracy the
only game in town so we are of course
approaching politics in a different
perspective when you do not look at
elections only as the only game in town
and that's what malli will do first
because he'll speak first
for only 15 minutes or for 15 minutes
only so that we'll have the time for the
key initiation to be really substantial
the title of his plantation is caste and
multiculturalism semi-colon slippery
slope to the end of inhalation thank you
I thank the organizers for having me or
and especially my friend Gendron
it's an it's an incredible honor for me
to be here with with all the wonderful
panelists since professor jafra
mentioned the EPW article i just
remember that i had call
electoral politics in India the ultimate
antidepressant so maybe we'll have a
chance to revisit that I have my reasons
for saying so I am I'm going to try to
be back on where we left off and then
move onwards to make way for the
afternoon panel to in some sense so some
years ago the african-american actor
Danny Glover complained that taxi cabs
in New York City did not stop for him
when he hailed them and in a trenchant
critique of multiculturalism from the
left legal scholar Richard Ford reminded
us that we should not think that Danny
Hale cabs in especially african-american
sort of away something like a black
cultural act that was not the reason why
catchy cabs did not stop for him cabs
obviously does not stop for Danny simply
because he was black and we need to
remember that according to Richard Ford
we can draw any number of lessons from
from this including speculate on the
fact that many taxi cab drivers in the
city are of South Asian descent and how
new immigrants quickly learn how to
racial eyes but I actually want to focus
on only one lesson in order to make only
one point in the fourteen and a half
minutes left about caste in the Indian
case and that is that racial
discrimination is not about culture but
it is often thought to be so this is a
point stressed by Ford and I want to
keep that in mind and of course Danny
Glover was not contributing to cultural
diversity in any way when he was hailing
a cab so I want us to launch into
something about caste consider the
following three discourse is already in
place in in the Indian context today the
first is what I shall call state speak
from the corridors of power in his
thirteenth Lester Pearson memory lecture
at Delhi University in 2007 India's then
Commerce Minister mr. Jayram Ramesh who
is now the environmental Minister spoke
of how
dear managed its incredible diversity
visa vie other euro American nations by
saying the following I begin the core
indeed India has the greatest diversity
seven major religions and numerous other
sects and faiths 22 official languages
and over two hundred recorded mother
tongues and around four thousand six
hundred and thirty five largely and
arguments communities and quote the
number four six three five of course
refers to six hundred and forty five
Cheryl tribes our SD groups and the rest
three hundred and three thousand nine
hundred ninety caste groups which
anybody who has even a cursory
understanding of India knows that that
number keeps changing depending on how
we count but at least that's an
approximate thing so that's the first
discourse in place state speak the
second is expert speak from the Academy
political scientist Ashutosh Varshney
argues that the four that four kinds of
social diversities in India namely
language diversity tribal diversities
religious diversities and caste
diversities have each been sought to be
politically accommodated within india's
power structure namely through the
policies of federalism that is for the
linguistic and tribal diversities
personal laws that is for the religious
diversities and affirmative action or
reservation for caste diversities
speaking about caste in the language of
diversity is not something new but it is
definitely gaining a lot of ground and a
number of scholars seem to have adopted
that none of whom I believe have any
doubt that caste is also very much about
inequality I just want to put it out
there that the language of diversity is
already in place other scholars for
example have spoken of caste as ethnic
groups so so this is also something very
much in place the third a kind of
discourse which is in place is what I
would call an intellectual activist
subaltern speak for we all know that sir
Waltons do speak in January 2002 the
Bhopal document was released as a Dalit
agenda for the 21st century
and this is perhaps in my opinion the
first large-scale attempt to put forward
a case to address caste ISM against the
list using the language specifically of
diversity writing about this initiative
political scientist sham babu who's also
a major participant in drafting the
document notes that a key rationale of
the document was to make a case to
address exclusion and
under-representation of the list in the
broader economy by calling for workplace
diversity in place of reservations
because the policy of reservations
lacked norm Dalit approval and was
viewed as too rigid with its stress on
quotas so this is a rationale let's go
with diversity because there's a huge
simmering at least and sometimes coming
out backlash against reservations in a
special section titled diversity the way
out that document makes clear that it is
borrowing from the US model of a field
of affirmative action and diversity
practices within American corporations
in another section title conceptualizing
the Dalit agenda that introduces a
document the prime place of the
diversity principle is acknowledged in
the following way
and the core is the issue of diversity
and democratization of all walks of life
has been the mainstay of the Bhopal
declaration democratization of capital
and credit and ensuring a proportionate
share for the lits in the market economy
should be taken seriously diversity in
the workforce will be one of the major
issues that will be haunting the nation
in the years to come end quote now each
of these discourses puts into place a
particular connection between caste and
diversity that I wish to explore in the
remaining few minutes the reason we need
to be interested in this is because I am
arguing that caste has become a mark of
democracy in India today so that when
particular things happen to it
conclusions and claims are made about
Indian democracy in in the short
paragraph that we all received as
panelists as to what what this panel is
all about we were asked to also think
about shining India the mantra that has
not gone away
and it is definitely still believed not
only by the ruling classes by an ever
shrinking middle class - and two of the
pillars of shining India are economic
growth and of course democracy and I've
always wondered why the claims to
democracy in India are not as well
challenged or a strongly challenged as
the claims for a kind of a neoliberal
globalization that has benefited all
that claim has been challenged in an
incredible number of ways and continues
to be but I have wondered why the claim
to democracy has not been challenged as
strongly as it could be or ought to be
even in the face of such massive witch
hunts as operation green hunt which is
currently underway in large swaths of
India and the daily assaults on the
tenuous Democratic fabric of everyday
India including judicial assaults so at
some point we have to face up to some of
these issues and I'm not saying we don't
but I wish we did more in other words I
am interested in how India appears
Democratic or how the illusion of
democracy is maintained I believe it's a
very useful task to engage with so part
of the reason for the continuing
legitimacy to the claims of being
democratic is that is the quantitative
fact of much larger numbers than ever
before of the lips OB seas and women
seemingly participating in the political
process we are the formation of
political parties legislative
initiatives such as the panchayat raj
institutions that mandate women at the
lowest levels of political office and
the extension of reservations this fact
has not unreasonably been viewed as a
positive sign of a vibrant democracy in
India and some have even hailed it as
revolutions and I don't have a quarrel
with that term at least right now but I
want to shift a little bit and make
another point related to that and that
is that there is a far more silent
revolution that has taken place in India
and is currently still taking place and
it's a revolution that I would think
the counter-revolution really because it
has made it even more difficult to
challenge India status as a democracy
and this is the fact that caste has
incredibly and almost silently
legitimized itself as cultural identity
or as ethnicity and now caste difference
is conflated regularly with cultural
difference caste ism in my opinion has
become cultural caste ISM and we can
talk a little bit about that when the
time comes but definitely all of this
threatens to occlude any more scrutiny
of caste and India's democracy for a
long time to come increasingly both
within and outside India caste groups
present themselves as cultural groups
such that such that caste comes to be
viewed embodied and performed by social
actors simply has pre-existing cultural
difference rather than a socially
constructed relations of inequality and
socially ascribed forms of identity in
other words cast in globalizing India
has revitalized itself made itself anew
as cultural community or semaj and this
it has done by claiming to be less about
blood and more about culture cast ISM to
continues unabated as cultural caste ISM
or simply as a benign practice of what
pierre bourdieu would have called taste
or preference rather than as caste based
monopolization stigmatization exclusion
and exploitation for example in Hindi
one can find caste being presented more
more as being about canteen ransom or
lifestyle based cultural traits rather
than as in snitch hi-low ranking and
things like that
and I have called this as the
culturalization of caste in distinction
to the ethnicity of caste which we can
touch upon later if we have time to now
Ambedkar if he were around today he
would be gasping at how his one's
radical phrase calling for the
abolishing of caste which is actually he
used a polishin of caste a lot more in
that annihilation of caste peace then he
used annulation but it meant the same
but it also gives us a clue as to
America's way of thinking but he would
think that
his phrase now appears very quaint to us
it it was a phrase that plays the law
and legislation at the heart of social
transformation even while educating and
agitating to organize social movements
for change Anthony Appiah a scholar of
race notes in the u.s. context of race
versus ethnicity that unlike race which
appear admits could wither away in the
US could go away at some point unlike
race ethnic identities seemed likely to
persist so long as people are raised in
families which means forever perhaps so
if we bear that in mind along similar
lines cast as a cultural iced element
cultural lies principle has become even
more durable by laying claim to the
terrain of culture and tweaking its
grammar let's go back to Kasten
diversity now the bhopal document very
disappointingly does not show cognizance
of the sense in which the term diversity
is used in debates over affirmative
action in the US and we had a wonderful
wonderful source of information in the
previous panel president lee bollinger
who definitely touched on that but i
want to bring it out maybe even more
sharper in a post Bakke and a post gruta
scenario it has become very clear that
whenever the term diversity is used it
means
cultural diversity and not racial or
ethnic diversity in Indian context it
does not mean caste diversity which is
the way in in which is a sense in which
the bhopal document talks about supplier
diversity when they are saying you need
as a government to give out more
contracts to dull it businesspeople they
are not asking that favor because they
let business people do business in a
particularly the lit way
in fact Dalit businesses do exactly the
same kind of business in the normal way
but because of a caste society they
would not otherwise get that contract so
we need to find that kind of a slippage
occurring very easily caste diversity
becomes cultural diversity so for
example again as Richard for
put it bluntly the expectation derived
from a diversity policy and everybody
agrees that post barky the move has gone
away from discrimination towards
promotion of cultural diversity and
richard ford says an accord him if
diversity is the reason you got into
school you better get off your chair and
show us some diversity and quote that is
a person who's a diversity hire is
expected to bring cultural diversity and
this marks a clear shift from viewing
the higher as the effect of a policy to
redress an exclusionary practice and
this is not the sense that the bhopal
document intends to use the term but it
flirts with it and it does it very
dangerously further the indian
constitution itself distinguishes very
salacious lis between caste groups on
the one hand and religious linguistic
and tribal groups on the other the three
latter ones are included in the
constitution in order to preserve and in
some cases also produce the culture for
example article 29 ensures groups and
citizens having distinct language script
and culture having the right to conserve
them the inclusion of caste communities
on the other hand was only to ensure
that the lower caste especially the lips
were not excluded from equal
participation so I want to place that on
the table to that in our Constitution
the term diversity is definitely not
used as cultural diversity to mean that
3990 caste groups form 3990 cultural
groups they don't in fact we have had a
good amount of documentation that the
individual caste groups culture very
definitely gets derived from caste ISM
and the caste system in other words the
culture that we generally assume that
let's say a tribal group like the Nagas
have is not the same as
the assumption that any of those 3990
groups have individual and independent
cultures the only possible and disma
argument the only possible candidate for
this would be the large number of the
lead groups who have systematically
developed some form of an anti casteist
cultural identity that they look outside
of anything with caste for example
Buddhism to derive that identity and
professor Jaffa law has commented on it
if I have a couple more minutes I'm
gonna wrap up calm down all right
couple more minutes I'm just going to
rush through a conversation I had with
the Potter artisan in central India in
1996 Potter's in Chhattisgarh our OB
seas and in two districts in Madhu
Pradesh that the next state they are
SC's so here goes the conversation
between anthropologists and Potter and
the colleges why do you not exchange
food and daughters with those are the
Potters out there Potter because they
they are from another semaj or cultural
community but are they not also Potter's
do they not also work the wheel yes they
are Potter's who use the wheel but the
user stick to rotate the wheel and like
us we use our bare hands they are the
check Claudia Potter's whereas we are
the Gerry apotres these are two sub
cards so if they stop using the stick
will you have relations with them roti
bata Colleen then no we are from
different fear cos filters are in dogmas
marriage circles what about those other
potters who come to your annual so much
convention no they are from another
region originally whereas we are
chhattisgarhi they are not they are
different are they Potter's they don't
even do potting I hear that they do
clothing and marble business you're
right they are from Rajasthan and
Gujarat anyway why will they want to
exchange food and daughters with us we
are poor they don't like our rehn
Shahan there's a class element going on
such as well our women for example go
out on the streets to sell pots they do
not like it there women stay at home
okay how about those other potters
referring to a group of potters who live
in the same town but in another
neighborhood of Asti well they are
definitely not Potter's they raise and
eat pigs we do not what they call
themselves
whatever
kumar's they call themselves a curved
haru-kun ha yes but only name as I said
they are not Potter's they don't even
know how to work the wheel they make
only bricks also they are not from
jetties good but still persisting Li I
ask are they not also Potter's maybe but
if we start marrying them then what will
be the difference between us but why
should there be difference between your
groups all our Potter's after all is in
that so ah yes but they are lower than
us although they think that they are
higher in fact we look at the checker
Diaries as her regions this is a term
that is very much in use in India as
opposed to the legalese of the letter SC
we do not even take water from them
anyway when forced to reflect upon and
defend his practice of social
differentiation do la rue rom who's the
Potter readily admits that all these
cultural distinctions eventually give
way to pre-configured notions of
hierarchy and inequality between cars
and cultural difference reveals the
inequalities that it helps us change
thank you let me first of all thank
gender and Janki to invite me here it's
really a commendable job they have done
and organizing conference in honor of
Bubba's have Ambedkar and I'm sure 300
million of all the lists all of the
world will join me in appreciating this
act I am now going to talk about
reservation because the current
neoliberal paradigm has rendered it
meaningless I am NOT even talking about
a democracy because we call India as the
biggest and hottest democracy I am my
the lip is something like 80% of the
elite who live in villages and who do
not have any syrup access to anything
practically and that the hard reality of
their life is currently the atrocities
and I'm cook I'm focusing basically that
problem I make basically following five
propositions one the classical caste
system depicted by the pole harness
structure is almost dead in India to the
existent caste system in India is
concentrated at the lowest edge of the
caste framework marking the division of
costly non caste people three while in
urban area the caste system operates as
a system of premium and discounts his
most insidious expression in the vast
countryside is caste atrocities poor
caste atrocities are the best proxy
measure of the operational cost ISM and
provide meaningful metrics to understand
the contemporary form of HA and
contemporary form and its content and
fire any attempt to present cus in a
more complex manner amounts to obfuscate
their essential feature blur the vision
of the annihilation weaken the struggle
against them and only serve the
interests of ruling classes there's been
huge scholarly interest in caste system
and there has been long history of
antica struggle and the speed the
discourse and Castille trends in a
stereotypical manner taking them as an
amorphous continuum of hierarchies
sourced from Hindu Dharma Shastras there
is a kind of romantic delight in
amplifying the promise of this royal
institution as defying the expectations
of many including the likes of Marx that
it would crumble under the onslaught of
capitalism and forces of modernity the
problem with this kind of understanding
of caste is that it is utterly useless
in dealing with them accepting perhaps
for academic accomplishments and
political opportunism firstly such an
amorphous continuum is not I mean able
to break into the neat contending camps
with antagonistic contradictions the
resolution of which could be termed as a
resolution of caste issue secondly since
the continuum is supposed to
exist with the religious authority of
Hinduism one is mislead infer the
unleash Hinduism it destroyed Cosme not
be annihilated thirdly the continuum
with is inevitable fluidity in holding
innumerable cars in hierarchy entails
endless contention between them and
impasse it to kind of self regulative
perpetuity and fourthly in dealing with
them it impels people tower
directionally social engineering rather
than aiming at the volitional change
that this kind of deep-rooted venom
requires trusts are essentially
hierarchy seeking and hence pervasively
division the cut across classes tend to
germinate reactionary consciousness and
hence cannot be used for articulating
any radical struggle it is not to say
that Costigan that had taken place
during the last century did not have
radical content the indeed where where H
with radical vision and even
accomplished a significant change in the
lives of India sugars and artichoke
grass the worst victims of costs however
down the line the Intel determination of
cause consciousness and end living of
caste identities totally antithetical
development as far as their our
objective of annihilation of caste was
concerned in my analysis the main reason
for this paradoxical research lay in
their lack of grass of the essence of
castes to begin with and the failure to
keep pace with their subsequent
development if we see through the brief
history of encounters with castes we get
varied conceptions of cars depending
upon the intent of the definer colonial
rulers shocked us with their divisive
potential and promoted the
conceptualization in a manner in which
India appears on a civil society as a
bunch of communities worrying among
themselves non-permanent took thus at
the countenance of the outsider Aryan
conquerors the ancestors of the peasant
the Brahmins for enslaving
native people Dalit women particularly
under dr. Ambedkar came to the
conclusion that cows were an integral
part of the Hindu religious social
structure
and propose the announcement of Hinduism
to escape the caste bondage for the
Communists cos were just a feudal really
a part of the superstructure which would
automatically vanish when the economic
base is changed through revolution the
contemporary Bahujan bodies look at Cass
as an asset to mobilize the operation
masses into a constituency of 85 percent
to vanquish the 15% upper castes all of
these conceptualizations reflect very
degrade of theoretical confusion and
hence seem to lead to some kind of
reform is program to bring about
incremental improvement in the
conditions of the lower caste
contrary to commonplace notion casa be
changing all through history one can
easily note the momentous changes in
them during colonial period brought
about by the imperatives of colonial
rule and during the spread of capitalist
businesses and industries
post-independence modernist project draw
them further for the paucity of time I
would not go into the details how the
changes have impacted because what
however would be noted is that
notwithstanding the compromised
capitalism struck with feudal forces the
cause relations with the emergent
capitalist class where we tend to a
large extent the capitalist culture
certainly had a debilitating impact on
caste culture and traditions of these
communities leading to obliteration of
the ritual notion of hierarchy among
them and promotion of social osmosis the
capitalist class comprising
entrepreneurs and managers belonging to
veneers and diamonds and the business
communities like posses hoses and bors
largely overcome the classical caste
hierarchy and came closer as a class
they would however preserve caste
divided among lore to cast to keep their
feudal alleys in supply chain treat
please and to discipline the working
class in their own establishment with
his fatalistic ideology and divisive
ethos after independence the virtual
Angelo state that came into being in
India adopted the modernist Constitution
the sex is the state settled for
modernization because the feudal classes
also
prospects for the advancement through a
the Nehruvian modernist project
significantly comprised land reforms and
Green Revolution hugely enriched the
farming Childre cust who replaced the
upper caste landlords in villages with
this economic enrichment coupled with a
numerical strength achieved by
consolidating all the middle class with
rokkes they soon became an important
element in the political picture in the
post independence period in the context
of castes green tea pollution brought in
capitalist relations in the countryside
through development of cash economy and
markets for agriculture inputs outputs
and credit on the positive side for the
list it broke the backbone of Ballou
theory system but on the Digital side it
abolished many of their traditional
vocations without any alternative means
of livelihood the bellies were
increasingly pushed to workers should
reforms as landless labourers with the
displacement of traditional upper caste
line laws the baton of brahmanism were
builded by the nouveau riche sudra caste
Santhosh office tree of the former the
it's they expected that the lead to pay
them obeisance as they did to the upper
caste in a serious however the
consciousness gained by the lean through
the Dalit moment conflicted with this
expectation and contributed to build a
grudge against them
the Shudra us today dominate the
political establishment and our past
coming up in entrepreneurship
although the wishes in Burmese may be
very visible as leading the capitalist
establishment because of their first
more advantage the sugar curse of us
catching up with their advancement in
the economic and political scale the
ritual status as a classical inferior
caste who has almost vanished they have
not been virtual rulers of lorilynn they
know they have not been the virtual
rulers of rural India but have also
captured the fast developing small towns
the very discourse of the backwardness
which has dominated the socio-political
area for the last two decades is rather
the proof of the growing power it is not
that there are no quirk or backwards
among the sudras India where 78% people
subside on
the earnings of about 40 cents a day
suffer various deprivation and naturally
thought only with the poor and backward
people strewn across all castes in
communities thus however is not secular
poverty or backwardness it is about the
socio-cultural quasi racial prejudice
against certain people the most
concentrated expression of existing
caste his atrocities on the label while
delish were always wrong the phenomena
of atrocities could be marked in the
increased power asymmetry between the
lessee and sudras in villages it almost
begins with one of the first grave
atrocities we took place on 25 December
1968 in Kilburn many in old Tanyard
district of Tamil Nadu in which 44 the
least mostly women and children were
massacred by the landlords and their
henchmen it was followed by a spate of
had two atrocities all over the country
initially is even in Kelvin many the
atrocities came as a consequence of
class struggle waged by the communist
parties firstly by the parliamentary
parties in the light later by mudslides
a tricky one many it was cornea in Bihar
we saw the first cosmic massacre in 1969
then there were spate of killings all
Lord behalf or three decades it only
stopped when valleys began to retaliate
with the help of mudslides atrocities
mirrored the intricacies of social
dynamics Razavi caste as for instance
there has been qualitative difference
between atrocities earlier and now
earlier
atrocities were committed as a routine
with the assumption of absolute right or
beliefs with no sense of wrongdoing now
atrocities are committed with the sense
of loss of that right with the same sub
being wronged earlier
atrocities were committed in arrogance
as the least would not speak out now
they are committed in vengeance against
the lead assertion earlier atrocities
we're the manifestation of contain for
Dali's today they are a manifestation of
resentment against the three villages
the liftgate from the state there has
also been a difference between the
nature of atrocities earlier and now
earlier they were committed as an
integral part of the interaction between
the listener on the lips and his
to be casual more of humilating in
nature than of physically damaging today
they are far more violent and are in
nature of when a vengeance or punishment
they are therefore not only humiliating
but also physically destructive far more
brutal than before earlier atrocities
were mostly committed by individuals in
half of range now they are committed
collectively somewhat in a planned
manner in a mode of demonstrative
justice teaching a lesson the increasing
number of atrocities against the leaf in
recent years have been alarming enough
but the change in their intensity also
is noteworthy notwithstanding these
differences what lay at the root of
atrocities in any time is the asymmetry
of power the fact of perpetrators being
more powerful than the victims the
perpetration have precipitation of this
asymmetry occurs either in a routine
form when this asymmetry is legitimate
legitimate it by somewhere as in earlier
times or in the event of crisis as it
does now despite the seeming progress at
the least this asymmetry of power has
remained more or less intact as the
development paradigm during the
post-independence period helped the
least make some progress it has held the
cast exposes in far greater measure this
asymmetry express itself through the
familiar fault lines of cast for true
into atrocities wherever the cast
exposes experienced crises atrocities
data on which incidentally are
maintained by the government canceled
the best foxy measure for the existent
cast ISM the intensity of atrocities the
area in which they take place their
frequency their time series growth and
even the data on subsequent process of
just a delivery system in respect of
them provide good metrics to understand
cast and cast dynamics and Co
strategizing combat against them many
amid get exploded in their wake for
instance the myth of upper caste of
racers the myth of development dampening
the cause the myth of representation
logic dearly upheld by the lives
the myth of victims being the weakest
the myth of through vibrant and he
casteth
the myth of aggressive existence of
progressivism in India and in the
greatest myth of state being the plane
of the lid or at least impartial
mediator between the listen others that
all crumble at peril Angie it held out
mirror before us and showed us what
needs to be done all electricity's
unambiguously exposed that caste ism is
no more confined to civil society it is
well supported by the state apparatus
implying thereby that the anti-castro
sir is necessarily have to deal with the
state contrary to commonplace view the
problem of caste has become much simpler
today than ever before the existential
caste are confined to a divide between
the Lisa and monoliths quite like the
racial divide between blacks and whites
or cause division class division between
capitalist central it really no time in
history has rendered themselves as easy
for combating against as they do as they
do now the historical project of
annihilation of caste is most feasible
to accomplish than any time before
atrocities and the concentrated
expression of existing cars need to be
singularly targeted for annihilation of
caste bba s bba did occur while
explaining the rationale behind this his
declaration of religious conversion to
his Vanguard followers in 1936 had
basically developed his logic with the
very problem of atrocities he diagnosed
that caste Hindoo dead to perpetrate
atrocities on the lives because the
lease were too weak to retaliate he
therefore proposed a solution in terms
of supplementing their strength by
merging with some existing religious
community through mass religious
conversion seventy years ago in the
community charged atmosphere he could
speak of community and supplement to the
Dallas strange as it happened he even
did not do so in today's situation when
classes are plotting out of belief
bellies of caste
classes are sprouting out of bellies of
caste can we imagine of a class
supplement and example ebuy exemplified
by Gaia Johanna
in Bihar or Sundari and Andhra Pradesh
not only at the solution of atrocities
and in turn of caste but for doing away
most of operation and exploitation from
the Indian soil thank you thank you very
much and I'm sure we'll go back to
Kalonji during the Q&A session your
presentation will deal with effective
transfer policy options for the death
it's a real honor to stand before you
and share some of my views on the
subject while congratulating the
organizers I remain grateful for
bringing me here I have chosen a topic
under the broad title caste in
contemporary India effective transfer
policy options for accolades I have
chosen this topic not because I was
associated with common for a number of
years and I had an opportunity to look
at the policy makers at close quarters
but because common still remains the
largest source of Finance for the Dalits
and the issues need to be discussed
India is the typical example where the
mainstream policy makers consider that
the programs for the poor at best a
short term strategy or appeasement or
palliative and at worst the worthless
expenditure the strategy in mainstream
development policy so far has been one
of distributing subsidies in exchange of
pores right to vote it's not just a
distribution this exchange per pores
right to water the Knology behind the
rulers conventional political behavior
could be for the following reasons the
policymakers traditional apathy towards
salads as they constitute a sizeable
number among the poor illiteracy and
lack of political awareness among the
Dalits
poverty alleviation and not equity that
guides the policymakers the Dalits in
general are landless agricultural
laborers and any effective transfer such
as land could upset the prevailing power
structure in the village quality the
memorandum entitled states and
minorities by Ambedkar and submitted to
the Constituent Assembly on behalf of
the All India Shahrukh Oz Federation
included among other things protection
of Shahrukh cast against communal
exercies protection against social and
official tyranny why I am saying this
because he is going to suggest something
more to protect Scheduled Caste
that is agriculture as a straight
industry with a backbone of the
principle of no landlord no tenant and
no landless laborers as a permanent
solution to untouchability a separate
settlement must be created and I which I
am going to interpret it as separate
panchayat for palates and settlement
Commission to be constituted to hold
uncultivated land belonging to the state
in a trust for settlement of the shuttle
caste in separate villages and an annual
fund of rupees 5 crores for the purpose
of promoting the settlement this may be
5000 crores now but there may be more
fifty thousand crores also those days
the policymakers after all a breed of
the Indian caste society of vertical
gradations conceived by rationality and
governed with the intention of
perpetuating the dominant ascendance of
the dominant castes preferred not to
follow Ambedkar the vehicle for India's
recent growth economic growth it is
imperative to examine the transfer
policies of the Government of India
relating to the Dalits and the poor and
to take up questions relating to long
term effectively distributive measures
therefore the paper would focus on the
mainstream policy reforms in the wake of
India's recent growth and effective
transfer policy options the last 15
years witnessed a steady growth in the
Indian economy
the GDP at factor cost has been growing
at an enormous rate of eight point one
percent when compared to 30 years span
of 1950 and eighty one it was just
thirty three to four percent and even in
two thousand four and five it was six
percent now two thousand five when six
has Fitness 28.1% the exports have
nearly doubled from 2002 to 2003 US
dollars fifty two point seven billion
two years dollars one hundred and two
point seven billion in 2005 and 2006 the
total foreign investment inflow has
risen also I don't want to give the
figures because I will circulate the
papers later on the automobile sector
offers yet another dramatic expansion
the sales of passengers Lakers have
risen from seven lakh seven thousand to
1.4 million in 2006 the total number of
telephone lines through that 158 million
but it was just five million during 1990
91 out of this 158 million connections
117 point 2 or cellular the above are
some of the growth indicators that India
can really boast about there is no doubt
but this developments could have helped
India to emerge as a equalitarian
society had an aggregate trade-off
between the twin goals of economic
growth and reduction in inequality being
contemplated at the design level also
this development could have transformed
India from an basically agriculture
feudal economy into a modern one but it
has miserably failed the reason being
that the recent growth was rather
induced by the change in global trends
of technological innovations than by the
foresighted development policies of the
Government of India but I I totally
don't deny that this global brains have
been exploited by Government of India
for its own favor now as a result nearly
26% of Indian population is living below
poverty line the rural India remains
unchanged
with much of its population living in
the rural area nearly 77% live in the
rural area and the farmworkers are 58
percent the share of agriculture in the
GDP has fallen from 46% in 1970-71 to
21% 2004 and 5 now the Dalits are the
worst hit the incidents of poverty among
them is 35 to 40% the January 13 2002
copal declaration highlighted there was
not at the single Dalit billionaire
businessman or industrialist in a
country that produced world's richest
businessmen given the hope of getting
opportunities in public forms has become
irrelevant in the wake of privatization
I can give you some more indicators you
you just take the number of illiterates
or the number of unemployed youth the
number of bonded laborers the number of
child laborers and the Meccan mortality
infant mortality everything is high in
the live community so another important
factor featured by the recent economic
growth is the slow growth in the
manufacturing sector keeping in view the
highly capital and skilled labor
intensive nature of this sector in spite
of its contribution towards GDP it
cannot absorb the excess form labor
immediately and effectively
so therefore what is alternatives given
the above situation the economic
reformers for future India are left with
only three options one is immediate and
drastic reforms in agriculture sector
gaming distribution of assets and
resources to the rural land less
strengthening of rural industry or rural
services which are in the informal
sector and steady investment in
employment generating still development
but currently what do the economic
reformers think in India they see
reforms as subsidy elimination in
financial terms and in administrative
balances of good governance through
sheer force of commitment and power
exercised by honest officials
I can swear that neither of the best of
civil servants not the efficient of
private companies can bring back good
governance against distorted government
policies the government of India's
programs targeting the Dalits and the
poor can be broadly grouped into four
items because I want to give a picture
what are the schemes are implemented in
broad categories number one the
mainstream second the community third
the individual and the last the area
based programs under the mainstream
programs funds are allocated sector wise
namely agriculture industry power
irrigation of subtract the benefits are
expected to flow to the members of the
mainstream and to trickle down to the
poor to the community based programs
cover different disadvantaged
communities including the Dalits through
the reservation policy also the Dalits
and tribals are covered by the special
component plan and the tribal self sub
plant respectively the third categories
of individual and family oriented
programs are basically food subsidies
through public distribution system and
credit insurance facilities under
identified projects the area based
programs cover geographically
disadvantaged people living in the hill
and out prone areas now look myriads of
programs variety of programs considering
the multiplicity of programs
orchestrated by sound socio-economic
theorists worldwide economists will
conclude that the existence of
persistent poverty in India could be
only for two reasons one is lack of
resources
next is lack of good governance but alas
they would hardly detect the evil design
of caste in all such reform negotiations
for example what could be simply passed
over a strudel credit system by the
economists could be a system of bonded
labor in practice an outcome of the
caste system because the lower castes
are forced to work no free as free labor
the landlord's house similarly
out-migration of labor would simply mean
hazardous urban slums where the main
occupants are talents the belated wisdom
of garment of India that the Dallas
could hardly benefit from
the mainstream five-year plans resulted
in the announcement of a separate plan
for Dalits we will apportion resources
equal to the population of the Tigers
that was the announcement by the
government but what was in practice we
will see what is in practice the plan of
the government of India is merely to
guide the state governments from your
own pockets please allocate money I will
not see what is going on there the funds
allocated but it is not without its warn
traps and tricks the funds allocated
would be spent on two types of projects
one is divisible one is non visible what
is not divisible what is divisible
Catholics hardly have any say in the
matter
non visible projects meant regular
sectoral again square one agriculture
industry irrigation that is the normal
mainstream programs and divisible
programs are directly that teach the
Dalits which is normally a meager front
allocated for the purpose now after much
shouting by me and mr. Costas Gandhi in
the is now they have at least been
careful to show what is to be civil and
what is not divisible and they make it
equal but nothing reach the poor I am
coming to the point the divisible
projects target the specific needs of
the palace and only meager funds are
made available the ambiguity between
visible and non-visible has provided
ample scope for the tricks to be played
for example while the Dalit cultivate
it's not a joke please but in May it
looks like a joke
for example while the Dalit cultivators
constitute only 11 percent after total
valid population who normally won't add
it and semi-arid barren lands they are
expected to utilize 19 percent share
under agriculture sector which offers
schemes mainly to irrigated lands and
the government of tamil nadu rightfully
claims that 19 percent funds are
utilized for the Dalits in that sector
this may be the case of Tamil Nadu but I
can vouch in all the states in India it
must be the same similar is the case in
the power sector one-fifth of time
annual budget is allocated to the sector
to the sector power is considered non
divisible is it I think it sounds
ironical you cannot share power with
people the Dalits as landless laborers
are consumers of nineteen percent power
as per gampo cough accounts yet another
example is the transport sector where
the Dalits are neither the commercial
transport operators nor are they
contractors laying roads as sheer paid
passengers they are utilizing 19 percent
fronts of the government what is
relevant here is that unless Dalits are
landowners they would be kept away from
all economic activity see you cannot
reach the government you cannot reach
anywhere any corridor of power because
you cannot get irrigation you cannot you
cannot utilize the water you cannot
utilize the power you cannot borrow loan
seventy thousand crores of rupees have
been written off by the government the
loans had been that was the loan taken
by the agriculturist but the poor Dalits
had taken some petty loans the comment
was not willing to write it off and
there was nobody to ask that demand for
the same in the Government of India what
is relevant here unless the Dalits are
landowners they would be kept away from
all economic activities of the country
and even when the special components
plan is said to be enforced they would
not benefit out of it unless the divide
between the divisible and the
non-visible scrapped a separate planning
body is created under the Constitution
to look into the specific needs of the
Dalits because nobody wants to listen to
the needs of the talents what do I need
there are a number of theories they want
to propound and propagate and then force
them on us but nobody would like to
listen to us what do we exactly need
another major transfer policy now
another major transfer policy targeting
the Dalits and the poor is the
distribution of the essential
commodities like rice wheat sugar
etcetera through the previous periods is
the public distribution network what had
been initiated as a famine relief
program they quietly its soft landed as
a famine relief program
in the affected areas now it has come to
occupy the main scene and it is the only
program that is for the poor it is a
permanent program an annual expenditure
of twenty six thousand two hundred
crores is spent and it features sixty
six point five percent as administrative
cost such as procurement from farmers
hulling milling storage transportation
fumigation establishment etc etcetera
and only thirty-one point two percent of
the money is actually spent on
subsidizing the food grain much of this
is also lost in leakage and theft on the
way and badly thirteen paisa per rupee
spent on food subsidy actually reach the
poor but what reaches the poor whether
they are able to is whether it's
palatable that is a real question mark
on the fact that barely a third of
fiscal subsidy and a fair share of
special component plan if delivered in
the form of cultural land
preferably pitiless women I want to
quote I am NOT able to be in the gender
panel so I want to make sure that the
Dalit women get some lands and are
complete by the package of direct
subsidies by buying electricity water
and other agriculture inputs at one
stroke all the perverse incentives that
are at the root of the management
failure can be removed what are the
management failure corruption under
utilization of special component plan
funds division of period stock to open
market under way meant to card holders
adulteration etcetera so meaning that
has been in infesting the public
distribution system needless to mention
that Dalits and the poor are empowered
through such effective transfers to the
Dallas as a community which has been
long displaced and prevented from
ownership of land due to perverse
Crossley's I have to mention what is the
caste law the cost law says that the
Brahmin cannot touch the plow but he has
to own the land and the Dalits he cannot
own the land but he has to time so this
is the cost
therefore land is not merely a source of
livelihood but also central to the last
identity and culture realizing this and
keeping in view the number of atrocities
committed on the landless and the
illiterate among the Dalits because
there are people are talking about
atrocities and every day you witness
something but if you carefully study
each atrocities somehow or other related
to landlessness or illiteracy and we are
not targeting them directly realizing
this and keeping view keeping in view
the number of atrocities committed on
the landless and illiterate among the
Dalits Ambedkar said to Dalits he didn't
say to others he said to Dalits
education is our future no doubt whereas
land is our present as well as future if
only you have land you can educate your
children I can say that 70% of the IAS
officers the top bureaucrats they must
have had some landed property otherwise
they would not have reached I challenge
this factor maybe people here the
scholars who present here also I can
safely say that there must be warning
some land otherwise they cannot reach
this place there are some arguments and
look at the other side what do they
think about these programs because I was
not given an official forum like this
that's why I'm clearly indebted to John
Key and others because in India you
cannot address people like this
especially the Dalits and the others
together I can secretly talk to that
it's under the tree and I mean I am not
I will not be given a public forum and
if I'm given a public program a forum I
am supposed to conduct myself very well
so therefore i abstain sometime and so
this is the official forum so I can say
that I proudly admit and I say there are
some arguments from my friends and
colleagues who are and is one argument
is that while agriculture is being least
profitable for the existing land owners
are they are already overburdened with
debts a number of suicides you hear in
areas and then why do you want to burden
the Dalits they're so concerned another
suggested due to the growing demand of
power see look at even now we have power
cuts despite of the government spending
one-fifth of its budget animal if you
want to cut shot and give it to the
Dalits
where will we go for power but you will
come you will be adequately compensated
elsewhere where they will not say it but
all of them are of the opinion that any
attempt to meddle with land policy will
lead to large-scale violence because as
such chiral Anqi are wherever the
problem there are there's been bloodshed
and violence and need for comment
introduce a policy that way large-scale
violence and bloodshed what was common
among them was the consensus or quick
consensus was yes the previous has to be
scrapped no subsidy but what about land
reforms it is independent of land
reforms you scrap PDS but I am NOT going
to voice my opinion and about land
reforms even among the Dalits call is
one finds the subject of effective
transfers such as land has not become a
major preoccupation so that I don't want
to comment but the Dalits scholars are
here they can as well explain why they
are you know making a big statement
about such effective land transfer in
reply to the comments it may be stated
that large holdings through mechanized
cultivation and supported by credit
market links no doubt healed high output
and government interventions are
required only at the time of natural
calamities and credit market this is a
theory when there is a failure when
there is a natural calamity government
need to interfere but otherwise you give
them land large holding mechanized
cultivation agriculture is fine and
maybe subsidies sometimes this may be
true of land rich countries like America
and maybe the developed countries but in
India the land dynamics is quite
different as I told you already you know
the land tax they are charging now we'll
be surprised just four rupees per acre
whereas the Dalit landless agricultural
labourer
he pays two rupees for a small hammam
soap body soap
so the language served much subsidized
and he is not given land he is not given
electricity he's not given anything or
tall house nothing but he pays tax but
people are under the impression that
that it's don't pay tax always to live
on the government it is not so we pay
the highest tax in proportion if you
really take proportion to our income
therefore this may be true of language
and developed countries but in India the
land dynamics is quite different the
acid-based inequality is nurtured by
caste trichter have led a population of
nearly 260 million to object poverty
resulting an enormous social cost people
talk about equity and efficiency trade
of an agriculture but when they take
into account this wasteful poverty
perpetuating 260 million you know and
the costs involved in it they don't take
into account what kind of equity and
efficiency data if I don't understand if
economists are here they are supposed to
explain to me why you know they are not
taking into account this social costs
assuming that initial inequality in
terms of assets because we always speak
about initially inequality we are all
equal now but you have property I do not
anything so this leads to further
weakness and in that means indebtedness
so if you assume that initially
inequality in terms of assets as a
source of livelihood not any other asset
I may be having gold but as a source of
livelihood has a linear effect on future
incomes effectively on transferred is
the only option I talked about three
options now I come to only one option
that is the land transferred is the only
option left before the government it is
not left roof before the Dalits it is
left before the ground because it has to
change agriculture has to be modernized
it has to grow a triple the contribution
to GDP has to increase so it is the only
option left before the government at the
recipient level - unless one can
initially assure that hard work will
yield good result required result there
can be no productivity of any sort this
is I think proved Theory distribution of
land and accompanied Direct Subsidy
because there was an argument front of
the chief minister when I was secretary
a draw on tribal welfare she said oh you
want to give land to
Dalits as such they are you know even
multinationals are finding it difficult
to you know develop this land and make
agriculture profitable and you want to
give it to the poor Dalits now I've also
reminded the opinions never changed the
brittish's when they suggested land
should be given to the Dalits the
erstwhile Board of Revenue
of course dominated by the higher caste
they said the Dalits don't have clothes
to wear and how can they cultivate so
you know the opinions 100 years before
still persist with the government
however distribution of land and
accompanied by direct subsidy package so
it has to be accompanied by direct
subsidy in Avenel like electricity water
etcetera I am coming to the last
paragraph however the process of change
at the policy level is not easy Ambedkar
firmly believed that the destiny of the
disadvantaged Hoover will not change as
long as they are not made partners of
power his prime argument was that the
victims of Brahminical social order
needed a strong power to destroy the
power on the other side because it was
power that ultimately made one interest
dominant over the other
true to his sayings the early Indian
political situation featured a high
proportion of rural landowners and
members of dominant caste in formal
politics and it was their presence in
the Congress party that stood against
all land reforms the present era of mass
politics has proved no better as there
are political squabbles over allocation
of public finances between different
political constituency's now if you take
agriculture is there a separate
political constituency they are mostly
backward class landowners and higher
you know cast landowners they are a
different political constituency the
poor are the most backward class and the
Dalits
they are the different political
consequence they want finances so the
argument here would be because the well
the cultivators has a power bloc
claimed higher procurement prices from
garment you pay more price for my
product but the poor will claim give me
less enterprise for my food so
government test on
being these two political constituency
so the argument here would be that
homogeneous interests are created by
increasing the number of cultivators
every year through transfers for a
favorable agriculture policy you add the
number every year to the cultivator so
that the favorable agriculture policy is
shaped the retention of previous what
will happen to the PDS a massive
structure created twenty six thousand
two hundred crores if we still remain
only for those who cannot help
themselves Dalits can help themselves
please we must really ascertain that the
list can help themselves they are not
the people who are not cannot help
themselves the political economy of
India has demonstrated that growth
leading to high inequality and short
term measure to lower poverty can
coexist
there is no problem you go in one track
I go in one track I go with a begging
bowl and you will live in luxury this is
the common scene that you can witness
and comment the fact that inequality is
high need not necessarily mean that
there will be conscious decision to
lower it especially when the victims are
Dalits maybe if somebody else the
government will no rush to solve it if
it is the it is the past experience
therefore what do we do how others can
help how people care here and help us
the Dalits have to form national and
international coalition's that can
influence and force discussions first
because the subject is not being
discussed at all so forced discussions
on effectively on transfers and
decisions by the government
non-governmental organization and
monitor the outcome thank you very much
for the opportunity
thank you very much Shiva for Romania's
of the deficiencies of the state in
India and this pressing issue that is
land
you